WE HAVE APPREHENDED 52 PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH
AL QAEDA.
>> BRANDON JUDD, PRESIDENT OF
THE NATIONAL BORDER PATROL
COUNCIL, THIS IS THE WORST
POSSIBLE SCENARIO PLAYING OUT,
52 PEOPLE COMING INTO THE UNITED
STATES APPREHENDED IN PANAMA
WITH TIES TO TERRORISM BUT THE
BIG QUESTION, HOW MANY PEOPLE
WEREN'T APPREHENDED WITH TIES TO
TERRORISM?
>> THIS IS THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO, WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
ARE GETTING AWAY AND WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THAT MANY PEOPLE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SPOTTED WITH TIES
TO TERRORISM AND LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE CROSSING
BORDERS LIKE RUSSIA, ROMANIA,
ARMENIA, IS PAKISTAN, SENEGAL,
THESE COUNTRIES GENERALLY TEND
TO HAVE ANIMOSITY TOWARDS THE
UNITED STATES AND ARE COMING
INTO THE UNITED STATES BUT LOOK
AT THE NUMBER OF GOT AWAYS,
PEOPLE CROSSING THE BORDERS
ILLEGALLY THE GUN AND DETECTIVE
WERE DETECTED OR GOT AWAY,
500,000 PEOPLE WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THE 42,000 WHO GET AWAY THE
MONTH OF SEPTEMBER.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT IS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER AND
THAT IS SCARY AND IT NEEDS TO BE
A POINT OF EMPHASIS FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC BUT THEY DON'T
SEEM TO HAVE THE WILL TO SECURE
OUR BORDERS, TO MAKE IT SAFE FOR
THE CITIZENS OF THIS COUNTRY.
CARLEY: WE KNOW THERE ARE
STRETCHES OF BORDER THAT ARE NOT
BEING PATROLLED BECAUSE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS ARE BUSY
PROCESSING PEOPLE.
52 PEOPLE WITH TIES TO TERRORISM
THAT WERE TRYING TO INTO THE
COUNTRY.
WOULD YOU CALL THIS A NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS?
>> IT IS.
IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN WHEN YOU LOOK
AT WHAT WE DEAL WITH AND WHAT WE
FACE ON A DAILY BASIS AND
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER YOU
CONSIDER IT PEOPLE FROM
COUNTRIES OF SPECIAL INTEREST OR
COUNTRIES WANT TO DO US HARM
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DRUGS ON
TOP OF THAT AS WELL THIS IS
ALWAYS THE NATIONAL SECURITY%
NEEDS TO BE SOMETHING THAT IS
LOOK THAT HARD FOR US TO GET
THIS UNDER CONTROL.
IT IS NOT ROCKET SCIENCE.
THAT IS FRUSTRATING AND
UPSETTING TO THOSE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO PUT ON THE UNIFORM AND
PATROL THE BORDER.
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE GOTTEN THE
BORDER UNDER CONTROL BEFORE AND
WE CAN DO IT AGAIN AND IT
DOESN'T TAKE A LOT AS LONG AS WE
HAVE A POLICY IN PLACE TO ALLOW
US TO TAKE THOSE PEOPLE AND
REMOVE THEM IMMEDIATELY.
IF WE DON'T DO THAT, IF WE
CONTINUE TO REWARD PEOPLE
CROSSING THE BORDER ILLEGALLY WE
WILL SEE NUMBERS THAT ARE
ASTRONOMICAL THAT WE CAN STEAL
WITH.
CARLEY: CONGRESSMAN GONZALEZ
SAID WHEN HE SPOKE TO THE
FOREIGN MINISTER IN PANAMA HE
ASKED HER DOES ANYBODY IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION KNOW THAT
100,000 PEOPLE ARE HEADED TO THE
UNITED STATES AND TIES TO
TERRORISM THAT WERE APPREHENDED
AND SHE SAID SHE TRIED TO
CONTACT SOMEBODY IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THAT CAN'T GET A
HOLD OF ANYBODY.
HOW THAT AN ACCEPTABLE RESPONSE
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION?
>> IT IS NOT WHEN YOU CONSIDER
WE HAD THE SINGLE LARGEST
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION LAST MONTH
THAT PLAYED OUT IN FRONT OF
EVERYBODY, DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
MEDIA YOU LOOK AT, IT WAS THERE
AND WHEN YOU CONSIDER 234 MILE
STRETCH OF BORDER DEL RIO COVERS
WE DIDN'T HAVE ANYBODY OUT THERE
BECAUSE THEY WERE ALL UNDER THAT
BRIDGE TRYING TO HANDLE THAT
CHAOTIC SITUATION.
IT IS WHAT WE SEE EVERY DAY AND
THE FAULT OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
CARLEY: CHRIS MAGNUS'S
CONFIRMATION HEARING YESTERDAY,
WE LEARNED IN 2007 THERE WAS A
LAWSUIT BY SEVERAL BLACK POLICE
OFFICERS AND THEY CLAIM HE MADE
SOME RACIST JOKES, STOPPED THEM
FROM GETTING PROMOTIONS.
THE JURY FOUND HIM INNOCENT BUT
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
SITUATION?
>> IT IS CURIOUS THE FAR LEFT AS
LONG AS YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE,
IF YOU HAVE ANY ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST YOU, THE FAR LEFT WILL
CONDEMN YOU INCLUDING THE BASE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION RELIES
UPON YET IF IT IS AN ACTIVIST,
SOMEONE WHO BELIEVES IN BEING
ACTIVIST EVEN IF YOU HAVE A
UNIFORM ON THEY WILL FORGIVE YOU
AND THAT IS WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
IN THE CASE OF MAGNUS WHICH IS
SO HYPOCRITICAL OF THE FAR LEFT
WHEN YOU DEAL WITH POLITICS AND
PUT THAT IN LAW ENFORCEMENT IT
DOESN'T BELONG AND AGAIN IT IS
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
AND JUST CAN'T.
CARLEY: MAGNUS WAS ASKED ABOUT
BORDER PATROL AGENTS, THEY WERE
FALSELY ACCUSED OF WHIPPING
MIGRANTS, THOSE IMAGES ARE
CALLED TROUBLING BUT THE
INVESTIGATION NEEDS TO PLAY OUT.
YOU HAVE AN UPDATE ON THAT?
>> WE DON'T AND IT HAS GONE PAST
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION SAYS IT
WAS GOING TO GO PAST.
THERE ISN'T ANYTHING WRONG SO
THEY HAVE TO OVERTURN EVERY
STONE TO FIND SOMETHING WRONG.
WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID THOSE
AGENTS WILL PAY, THAT IS A
QUOTE.
THE INVESTIGATORS OBVIOUSLY HAVE
TO COME UP WITH SOMETHIN